好きだってんがオウンゴール
疑い
n
こんにちははじめそうですはずミューズベントパークには実は隠れた場所にいろんな店
があるんです
ここもその一つもうここに住み外れて3年くらい経ってるんで結構モードが
めちゃめちゃ多くてりれないものとかって来たなとかに入れるんですよ僕けっこう男性
でもの捨てちゃうんですってないってなると中で当たっ
レアなんですよた本
中には多分えっそんなまで入れちゃうみたいなものが入ってたりだが僕は今見て喜ぶな
ものが入ってるような気がするです今日
なんで今日なんだいつでもそうですなかなかこういう店を開ける機械とかないんで
ちょっと今回はこの店の中をちょっと全部見ていこうかなと思っておりますっていうの
に今日の動画はからなんだかおお
います
そんだけ
いやねぇ待ってくる待ってくださいフォルダーの祖母とろしければたぶんすごいレアな
ものとかたぶん音から的なものが出てくると思ってるんでまぁそこも含めて表のみ
どころかな
やっても3年住んで買っても大切なものばっかり入れてる気がするんで
上げますはい
もう
パッと見ちょっとまあや汚い暗いですかねまあまあ
安心せいきっとこの中には驚きをの宝物が入っていることが使いたいと思っています
だって俺さぁほんとすごい段差になんですよね入らないものかザッパしからせてるんで
捨てずにとっておくってことはなかなかすげーものが入ってると思うんですよ
折り紙です
エアーもっとやばいが入ってますよネクタイを塗らずの滞在コンセント
あっホッケんだ旅水中ポッキーが入ってるこれでも誕生日ってあの俺が誰かさんから
もらったやつだ
もうあんっでも基本で来ても ok が多いなああああああああっ
でまあいろいろ探したレンズカバーが一眼のレンズカバーなくて超困ってたんですよ
あれでもカメラもなくしたんで別 nice ああああっ
小嶋陽菜の写真者があ
わーもう
ファーよかった見つかっておりこだまに定期的に読まないと生きていけない気がすんだ
よ結局だかよくわかんないのが多いですよね
なんだこれなんぞ謎なんだろこんな買ってるんだよ噛みやばいできる機械みたいですね
オーナー可能とリーダーウィングに市は何かちゃんと勉強してた
グラディエーターるっていうすごいながら勉強してだなぁと思います
やっぱねーやるときはやるんすやるときはやる男だったんでね昔は青いスーツ着ること
がなかったです
あマーサ家から借りてとバイオハザード変更シーズンのやつですねカメラのゴミとかも
入ってます
ばっっ ps vita だやばいいろいろやバー水メイト行った esb たバス
どこ行ったかと思ってたらこんな場所にあったのか
で自分やって
何だろうよかった強引なくなるんですよねらーゲーム機って結構割れじゃなくなりだぜ
な気がするんですよね
よかった見つかって
これなんか動画で使ったことあるなぁ俺だけ上が正しければ道で使ってた気がします
俺空世界的に有名なファッションデザイナー足腰よは小田紙兎ロペの金田2016年な
ちょっとどんどん見ていきますファイルのお手が強いわな字汚い汚い黒いくらい季ぶり
のおもちゃです安倍日本大みると結構英語の勉強してるんですよね英語系がすごい多い
気がし
ます思うラブライブのほのとするとカードが入ってます
ん
ダメなんか大学時代のものが多いですねー
toeic 対策ノートか白紙だ何を対策してねそれにダメージ万惣アキラ先輩じゃ
ないですか
ああああああ
うーんまあもうなんだこれ何のスピーカーやのスピーカーおいております次使いたい
ところがあるんだねーここらへん弾結構ゲームゾーンですねアームズとか
ポケモン意識とかおいておりますまとめてゲーム機入れたんだがこれは多分
これゲームポップ
このてびっくりそう
待ってなにこれこわいこわい公約は主戦ちょっと閲覧注意でいいですか今のこのこの
コレなにこれ何でなくが生き物のフンとかじゃないよね大丈夫だよね待って本当に怖い
や sumco の迎え月のなんか
アリア手足が父切れてずーっと奪って一気に強くなっちゃった
もう最悪だやったぜ黒いで隠させていただきますよ
なんで乗るのこの店が一番楽しいですね後半の通りね大マザーズ大好きなんていう間冊
の手帳が入ってますこれめっちゃであって高いんですよですかこれ何を持ってるんだろ
なんか
おでんのキーホルダーもめちゃくちゃ買ってましたッパこれはう
[音楽]
ええええええ
待ってくださいん
待ってくれこれにそういう趣味や姉うんリーダ b 層懐かしい
デジヴァイスだデジモン進化させるやつです何かゲーム系がすごい os ねやっぱり
もう孫六あードアで使ったやつなぜかをゆるあれをもう
移った
アニメが次々でもアニメがばっかりカツ取ってたっていう通知がありまして
あでもなーんては多分そんな取り上げるものがないはずだと思います車次もう一度目
いきますファ
製品化とどせいさんですかわいいでしょもう笑えも自分のグッズかな
俺の目覚まし時計ポケモンの攻略本すこれあれ買うだけでマスターボールもらえるんで
マジで買いました
うわぁ
びっくりした魚菜訳だあーするだと思った今ざっけんなよねめっちゃなかに蛇が入っ
てるんですけどたぼれなんだろうけどねやった人はおらなぁ怖いなぁ怖いなぁと v
ジャンプめっちゃ服買うんですよマーケットカードが付いてくるんだよファイナル
ファンタジーなんで買ったんっていうくらいたくさんボンッ
な役だと思ってたぜ
[音楽]
まあやバイク等のという子ジャマって惚れやばいぞやばいぞこれ
これ流れたも flac あってこれやばこれ茶目すぎずやだった気がすんだよなぁ
恋こんなもんですよねあとはそんなはあああっ
爆竹めっちゃ一転 the それじゃバック付きの数じゃないなぁ結構な爆竹の飾り
ます
どこからこんなの見つけてきたんだよそんな彼はこんなもんでございます次がラスト
うわぁ
ラストがヤバいすね多分ほぼ寝湯偉業だと思うんですよ
上から撮ってっていう技を以外のものがあったら反応しますその原則としてほぼ遊戯王
ランスやジョークねぇ yahoo
んーやっぱこれやばいもうベイベーどの昔のやつです強く屋さんで売っててレアすぎて
買っちゃいました確か
すごいなんかおしゃれなくるとあーこラブラブラフィーこのキングスライブこんなとこ
入ってたのか
アーデルですけどペラパップに30冊ぐらいはある v ジャンプが頭も結局いう業
関係ですねいやっっ
や有事を本当にはい
って感じですかねぇ
[音楽]
から付けたかーっ
me
uh
car
re だった